so I promise you guys I was going to do
a video in which I answer your Q&A
questions I got a lot of emails
thousands I want to thank my wife for
helping me sift through those because
there were a lot you guys sent me some
really fun ones some really strange ones
and that was interesting reading
but with my wife's help we shrunk those
down into 20 to 30 questions and I want
to answer those for you because you guys
help me reach 500,000 subscribers and
this is just my second way of saying
thank you
the first was the complete blu-ray
collection video and I thank you guys so
much for all the support you given me
over the years let's get going with
question number one as an aspiring
filmmaker what encourages you to do
genuine and original work taking into
account that recently the most
successful movies are sequels or cash
grabs and at the most original and
artistic films like enemy and babadook
usually go under the radar of regular
film viewers as an aspiring novel writer
myself I often Lee asked the same
question in my head and I'd want to know
your answer good question because really
it's important to recognize something
originality is hard to come by whether
you're a writer or a director or an
actor someone more than likely has done
something that you're doing before
already or whether you're just a
youtuber originality is hard to come by
what makes something original anymore is
your spin on it your style your personal
emphasis on your project whatever you
bring to it that's the unique part
because no two people are alike the
originality comes from being yourself
and letting your style make your project
unique and that's the same for youtubers
it's the same for writers directors
actors whatever you can personally bring
to something to make it more original
than perhaps it already is what inspired
you to start a review channel I've
always loved movies I've always loved
talking about movies I used to write
movie reviews on like Yahoo movies I
head up my own website it was called a
critics opinion it's not on the internet
anymore and I've always loved talking
about movies I've always loved making
movies filmmaking short filmmaking so
the next logical step was for me to
combine the two filming myself talking
about movies I love short filmmaking and
I love
so why not combine the two and make a
YouTube channel out of it and it worked
what is it like being married now I
guarantee the wife saved that one good
eye
I like it the thing is I I married
someone who has just the right amounts
of similarity and just the right amount
of contrast because there are things
that we can do together and it's awesome
but then there are things that she likes
more than me or does better more than me
and she fills in that gap she's able to
fill in that gap that I need and and
that's that's the beauty of marry you
find someone who is similar but also
fills a void that you need filled and my
wife does that perfectly there you go
honey I'm sure you wanted me to answer
that question which movies or books
inspired your imagination as a child oh
man
definitely Goosebumps books when I was a
kid those were the books that actually
inspired me to start writing when I was
in elementary school I would write
little short scary stories entirely
because I just love goosebumps so much
so the goosebumps as a kid definitely
inspired me quite a bit as I got older
Stephen King are their movies you love
that everyone maybe including yourself
considers bad and what kind of rating
would you give such a movie oh yeah I
mean guilty pleasures are big for me I
have a ton The Wicker Man with Nicolas
Cage I hate that movie it's terrible but
I also love it it's amazing and funny my
biggest guilty pleasure movie of all
time is Tomb Raider with Angelina Jolie
and I'm going to be reviewing that in
hilarious 'ti form soon I must I have to
at some point because hilarious tees can
be bad but they're funny or just amazing
movies that you love but you recognize
aren't that good and tomb-raiders a big
one for me hey Chris my question is this
what movie do you and your wife enjoy
the most to watch together if there is
no specific movie than what genre of
movie do you and her most like to watch
bond is a big thing for us our dance
song at our wedding with Skyfall who
would you rather interview George Lucas
or Steven Spielberg Oh Spielberg hundred
percent for one Spielberg inspired me
more and for two he's a much better
person to interview if you ever watch
interviews of the two Lucas is very kind
of like quick answers he doesn't ever
seem very happy
Spielberg just seems like more of a warm
person that you could talk to and learn
more about so definitely N+ as I said he
inspired me more if you were forced to
watch movie five times in a row which
would you choose the room or
Dragonball Evolution well the room
because room is hilarious and Dragonball
Evolution is my least favorite movie of
all time do you keep up with your
dancing and if so can we see some more
uh uh sometimes uh some people may not
know I used to dance like Michael
Jackson quite often in videos and yeah I
can still do it I just don't really keep
it up and that's funny you want me to do
it sorry no thanks not right now how did
you come up with the term get stuck mine
eyes and what made you start using it in
your videos
my whole thing on my videos is I don't
ever want to appear like I'm a
know-it-all or that I'm you know like
some big important person because I'm
not I'm just a guy in Ohio who loves
movies but there was a slight
contradiction there because my
catchphrase is my name and so it makes
me feel narcissistic the honest truth is
when I was on this old website called
blog TV there was like a live stream
website we could do like a web show for
people and some of my viewers came in
and they watched and we were just
talking about the fact that it would be
cool if I had a catchphrase and I just
had the viewers come up with things and
one person said how about gets stuck
mine eyes and I was like that's funny no
I'll never use that and then all these
people kept commenting that's hilarious
laugh out loud you know laugh my ass off
that's awesome I loved it and I was like
do you guys want me to say get stuck
mine eyes and universally everyone on
the show was like yes that's funny
and so I just started using it and it
stuck so the fans actually chose it not
me and that's the honest truth what is
the most satisfying bossfight you ever
played in the video game oh wow I know
the hardest one ever for me was Metal
Gear Rising I think his name is
Armstrong the final boss that guy was
insane when I beat him I actually felt
like I had accomplished something in
life it was crazy
satisfying boss fight man uh maybe the
end of the first Metal Gear Solid just
because it felt so thematically rich and
rewarding and it just affected me
emotionally which was rare for a game
back then I loved your Star Wars
analysis force awakens video but it did
kind of remind me of mr. plinkus review
style I was just curious if you were
paying homage to him or if it was just
an accident um I got a few comments
about that the thing is red letter media
is my favorite YouTube channel ever like
I
love them I love their videos and I've
been doing analyzed reviews in that
style for four years now ever since 2012
when Prometheus came out I've done ones
for enemy under the skin only God
forgives drive the prom with horror
movies today the problem with action
movies today I've done that style for
four years I didn't change anything
about it for my force awakens analysis
but I did get comments saying you know
this reminds me of red letter media or
are you copying off a red letter media
no absolutely not for one thing I would
never do that I love their reviews I
would never want to plagiarize someone
else's content also I just don't see the
comparison the only comparison I can
really see is that I'm doing a narrated
review with Star Wars footage
I mean planket is like a character he's
a drunk man who enjoys sodomizing his
cat while eating pizza rolls and locking
women up in his basement I mean I don't
really see the similarities there's
narration and I talked about Star Wars
and so I can see why some might have
thought that but no absolutely not
I would never copy off someone else so
yeah no absolutely not I love red letter
media and I have no intentions of ever
copying off of anyone
do you watch the nostalgia critic if so
would you ever want to do a
collaboration with him not only have I
watched nostalgia critic I've met him we
did a panel together at Wizard Khan in
Chicago we were on movie fights together
super nice guy we had dinner together
and yes we are planning to do a
collaboration at some point it will
happen eventually it was totally the
timing right you know it's a distance
thing really that's that's really all
that it is but yeah he's a great guy and
I love his video so I'm excited to do
that eventually what has been the most
challenging thing about making YouTube
videos um probably being scrutinized by
the public being in the public eye I
mean I really am just a person sitting
in my office talking about movies and I
know that for you watching it's
different but for me I just love movies
so I do get taken aback sometimes when I
see people so so angry at me for just
you know being honest
about how I feel about a movie I would
say that's probably the hardest part you
know I might say well the force awakens
was amazing or you know Spectre was good
and it's just like you're so dumb Chris
Stockman and I'm like why it's just a
movie and so that's probably the hardest
part for me is just the whole idea of
being honest about your opinion and then
seeing others get genuinely angry about
it
I think that's disconcerting to me is
probably the word I would use what would
be a piece of advice to give for movie
fans who want to start their YouTube
channel for reviewing please please be
yourself and I know that's a cliche but
it's true
don't look at my videos and attempt to
recreate them don't look at Jeremy
Jones's videos or someone else the flick
pic shows whoever don't look at someone
that you feel is successful and try to
emulate their path to success because
you know it's impossible you're you have
to find your voice you have to be
yourself and if finding your voice is
hard
maybe you just need to write a lot or
maybe you just need to film a lot to
discover your voice it's it's different
for everyone so my best advice would be
try do or do not there is no try
but what I mean is you just have to you
have to put that first step you have to
step out and do something you have to
actually sit down and attempt to create
something what kind of equipment do you
use for your videos camera editing
software mic etc my camera right now is
a Nikon d50 100 for some skits I use my
Nikon d800 and a 50 50 millimeter zeiss
lens the camera is sometimes I change
out sometimes depending on like what I'm
doing if I want to get more depth for a
skit I might even use the iPhone it's
just like I use those three things in
conjunction my mic is a tascam dr-05 and
use Final Cut Pro when I edit now you're
probably going to try to get that mic
and then get that camera and if you want
to create the same thing I have you have
to realize that there's a lot of other
things I do as well like color
correction and I do audio editing for
instance for the next 20 seconds in this
video I am NOT going to apply a single
color correction to it and I'm not going
to do any audio editing so you can hear
what it sounds like
before I do all of my post-production
work and here we go this is what my
video would look like if I did
absolutely no editing to it whatsoever
did no audio editing and this was the
sound you got and this was the
presentation you got so yes it is not
just the camera it is not just the
microphone it is also the
post-production editing that I've taught
myself to do in regards to color
correction and audio editing and big
thank you to skipper Martin a colorist
who lives in California who's taught me
a lot about color color grading super
nice guy super awesome guy hope you're
watching and yes so let's get back to
the nice presentation please okay there
you go
so yeah all those things in conjunction
with actually learning how to edit and
create good video and good sound or very
important have you ever considered re
reviewing any films to see if maybe you
were too hard or too easy on them the
first time like a bit more analysis and
whatnot absolutely in fact I'm going to
do that very soon because I'm about to
review the amazing spider-man and
amazing spider-man 2 in my series of
spider-man reviews that I'm doing
that'll be in the next few months and
yeah I mean I reviewed those technically
back in the day and I'm going to be
reviewing them with updated thoughts
because very rarely but every once in a
while an opinion can alter a little bit
over time for me you know for other
people maybe different but for me I
usually have pretty much that's how I
feel and I can pretty much get and but
for some reason with those two
spider-man movies my opinion changed and
I'm excited to talk about that is it
hard to not always follow the hype train
are you sometimes afraid about the
popular opinion on the movie you're
reviewing let's say that there's a
really shitty movie out and it becomes a
joke or a meme does it affect your
review in any way good question
really good question because that is
something that can be on anyone's brain
you know like I'm sure that for the
first like 100
so reviews of the force awakens that
were all positive that one guy he came
out and said I don't really like this
movie he knew he'd get hate for it my
review of lady in the water for instance
overall I think it's an average movie
but a lot of people hate it and I had to
take all that just throw it away and
focus on talking about the movie and
that's really important for me is not
listening to everyone else's opinion
like when I reviewed Jurassic world I
was like guys it's fine it's fine a lot
of people were like oh my god greatest
Jurassic Park of all what's so good I
just had to be like it's it's fine it's
not great but it's fine and it's hard
for me sometimes to deal with all that
noise and compress it but I try my best
how do you define the term narrative in
the context of a film and how does it
differ from something like plot or story
Wow okay for me personally I think of
narrative like a thread like an actual
physical string tied to the beginning of
the movie and tied to the end of the
movie and if that string stays level
then they probably did a good job but if
the story is messy and certain elements
of the movie fill out of place then
maybe that string gets tangled up along
the way and it's no longer a nice
straight line to me that's my best way
of visualizing what a narrative actually
is have you ever seen a movie that you
really didn't like but you can't
disagree that it is a good movie in my
case it's Hotel Rwanda really great
question because there are movies I've
watched and I'm like very good movie
never want to watch it again never
wonder what didn't enjoy watching it
very down depressing you know movie that
just makes you feel like oh god like I
don't I don't ever want to think about
that movie again for me that movie is a
Clockwork Orange
I love Stanley Kubrick's movies I really
do but I could never sit down and watch
that movie again it's a brilliantly
directed movie very well acted very well
shot but my god it is just disturbing
and I just I can't personally ever see
myself watching it again do you regret
saying that the force awakens was your
favorite movie of the year when people
will sent you so much hate for that no
no because I was honest about my opinion
I would regret
if I lied then I'd regret it but I
didn't I told the truth
so why would I know no what was the
first movie you saw in theaters um my
parents were really smart and didn't
take me to a theater until I was six
they were like no we're not going to
take me to a theater when he's a baby he
can annoy everyone else when I take him
when he's ready when he's mature and I
saw the Lion King and I'm pretty sure
that was my first movie in theaters
because I can visually remember going
and just being blown away what is your
favorite movie review you've ever made I
don't know about movie review but video
my Toonami retro rewind I love that
video I got to interview Christopher
Sabbath the voice of Vegeta he said my
catchphrase as Vegeta he did a whole
speech as Vegeta Steve Blum was in the
video and I met him in real life two
super awesome guy for goodness sakes
yeah that was that was big for me and
that made me feel really happy because
it wasn't just a video that I was proud
of in regards to how it was made but it
was a video that I loved making and
that's that was the most important part
for me so those are my answers to some
of the questions you guys sent me thank
you so much for doing that I greatly
greatly appreciate the fact that you
guys sent me so many questions so many
that I was blown away I was like ah oh
thousands and I just I really appreciate
it you guys are so great that is my
ultimate thank you for allowing me to
reach 500,000 subscribers and for always
being there and watching my videos and
supporting me it's something that I
really want you to know doesn't go
unnoticed I really appreciate that so
thank you so much guys if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes